j'ai pas mis le micro 1 et un problème
avec
ce que vous nous entendez
on entend pas le sens forum
est-ce que maintenant vous nous entendez
je monte un peu le son aussi pour moi
ok
est-ce que tu peux parler
on entend pas l'invité ça marche pas
qu'est-ce que j'ai dû faire
alors je donc c'est la première fois que
je fais ça donc fallait s'attendre à des
bugs
c'est plus moi qui sait pas configuré
pour l'instant
[Musique]
reparle un peu Michael
toujours pas
comment ça marche
est-ce qu'on m'entend toujours pas
[Musique]
il y a un parfait
à ils entendent ça y est
faut que j'arrête de dire des bêtises
alors
pourquoi j'ai des retours je sais pas
comment les éviter
[Musique]
ok ma petite classe ça va être mieux non
en tout cas on peut commencer à un petit
peu puis je vais essayer de m'habituer à
ça je suis écouté que d'une seule
oreille comme ça je
le retour sur me dérangera pas trop je
réfléchirai comment à résoudre ça plus
tard
bah bonjour à tous et bienvenue alors je
vais vous présenter cette nouvelle
émission qu'on lance sur scène Fall donc
l'idée c'est il y a beaucoup de contenu
géniaux sur Youtube et je trouve qu'on
en parle pas assez on parle beaucoup de
choses pas bien sur les réseaux sociaux
et donc là l'idée c'était de d'inviter
des gens qui ont produit des contenus
considérés cool
et
les entendre parler de la production de
ces contenus de leur point de vue de
l'histoire des contenus qu'ils ont
produit des messages qui veulent
communiquer et ainsi de suite et en
particulier la manière dont on va
choisir des gens invités c'est en
fonction de la qualité des vidéos
d'après les jugements des contributeurs
sur la plateforme tournesol donc si vous
êtes là je devine que vous savez ce
qu'est tournesol mais bon juste au cas
où je mets quand même un lien de ton sol
dans le chat
et donc le premier invité de cette série
du coup je suis heureux d'accueillir du
coup Michael Ruf
bonjour Michael
bon bonjour est-ce que tu pourrais
commencer par te présenter notamment ton
parcours
ouais déjà merci moi c'est mon premier
live donc je suis très content de le
faire chez sciences for all j'aurais
préféré que ce soit chez Hanouna mais
apparemment il y avait plus de place
donc moi je suis
j'ai fait un parcours universitaire
assez classique
licence j'ai fait une licence à de
biologie cellulaire et moléculaire à
Nantes et ensuite je suis à la fin à la
fin de ma licence je savais déjà que je
voulais faire de la recherche ce que je
fais pas finalement mais donc je suis
parti faire un master sur Paris et
ensuite j'ai fait une thèse à Rennes
et puis ensuite j'ai fait quatre ans de
pause doctorat à Nice et donc là j'ai
fini il y a un an mon poste doctorat et
depuis deux ans je me suis lancé dans la
vulgarisation scientifique en ouvrant ma
chaîne qui s'appelle donc la biologie
fait des vidéos
que j'ai pu commencer en fait en mars en
mars 2020 donc au moment du confinement
du coup tu fais vraiment ça à temps
plein ou est-ce que tu as d'autres
activités à côté
en fait du coup je me j'ai lancé mon
activité à la rentrée et là il y a en
septembre
donc l'idée c'est de faire des ateliers
des conférences des choses comme ça et
là je travaille aussi pour la fresque du
climat je sais pas si tu connais mais
non tu peux en parler
du climat c'est un atelier de 3h
qui permet de
de former un petit peu le grand public
aux enjeux climatiques de bien
comprendre les causes et les
conséquences
c'est une première approche du climat
qui est très intéressante et
participative
c'est une association
à but non lucratif mais ça c'est une
grosse association là la fresque du
climat il y a eu je crois que pour la
fin d'année on vise un million de
personnes formées
c'est surtout en France mais ça
s'exporte aussi à l'étranger et c'était
il y a plein d'autres fresques que la
fraise du climat aussi la phrase de la
biodiversité la phrase du numérique qui
reprennent le modèle de la fresque du
climat ok une phrase du numérique
non je sais pas du numérique mais non je
connais vraiment que la fraise du climat
pour l'instant j'ai été formé cet été
donc
OK
et donc nous ta recherche c'était sur
quoi en gros les sujets
si je prends juste le
temps de seconde je vais essayer de
m'éclairer
si je reprends juste le mon sujet de
post doctorat par exemple c'était sur la
matrice extracellulaire dans le cancer
donc pour faire assez simple en gros
dans des tumeurs il y a les cellules
tumorales donc qui prolifèrent comme des
malades et qui envahissent un petit peu
tout et puis il y a tout ce qui est à
côté donc tout ce qui est cellule
normale donc par exemple
les cellules immunitaires les
fibroblastes donc les fibroblastes c'est
des cellules qui font
qui font les cicatrices par exemple
quand on se coupe
si on a une cicatrice et les fibres
blast qui vont remettre de la du
collagène et tout ça pour pour
cicatriser tout simplement et en fait
dans une dans une tumeur toutes les
cellules normales elles finissent par
être un peu piratées entre guillemets
par les cellules tumorales
pour les aider à se propager donc par
exemple les cellules immunitaires elles
sont elles sont inactivées parce que
sinon elles vont détruire la cellule
orale et moi je travaillais plutôt sur
les fibroblastes et en fait les cellules
orales par exemple elle demande entre
guillemets aux fibroblastes de faire des
des autoroutes pour changer d'organes
qu'est-ce qui t'a poussé à te lancer
dans la vulgarisation
ce qui est un déclic ou est-ce que ça
fait longtemps que
moi déjà quand je voulais faire être
dans la recherche je voulais pas être
chercheur je voulais être plutôt mettre
de conférence j'ai toujours aimé le fait
de
d'enseigner des choses aux gens et déjà
en thèse j'avais fait une formation
doctorale de vulgarisation scientifique
ou on fait faire un film de 5 minutes
sur nos activités de tête de recherche
de test
donc
j'avais j'avais l'intention
continuer et puis après il y a YouTube
qui est arrivé et
le problème c'est que tu n'as jamais le
temps de le faire donc
je me suis pas lancé tout de suite et je
me suis lancé que quand il y a eu le
confinement où j'ai eu un petit peu de
temps libre
même si je travaillais quand même mais
j'avais un peu plus de temps pour pour
lancer ça et puis il y avait cette
histoire de covid aussi où j'avais envie
d'en parler donc donc c'est comme ça que
ça a vraiment commencé et puis après
j'ai essayé de me tenir à peu près une
vidéo par mois je crois que
donc parlons de vidéo je pense on va
passer à jump partie de on va parler un
peu de quelques vidéos
particularité en fait je vais pas
commencer par celle là
j'ai changé un peu d'image
attends on va faire top 3 en passant du
au top d'après le classement du
tournesol donc la première vie vidéo
dont on va parler donc c'est si cette
vidéo que s'appelle j'ai même pas le nom
c'est trop petit pour que je le vois
mais qui parle du coup d'aviation vert
est-ce que tu peux nous résumer un peu
rapidement cette vidéo
ouais alors ça c'est une vidéo qui est
un peu spéciale parce que c'est pas moi
qui l'ai écrite
en fait j'avais travaillé avec j'avais
fait deux vidéos sur les avions une
première sur avion et climat et je me
défais corriger le script par une
personne du shift Project qui s'appelle
Julien marcinkowski
donc il fait des conférences sur le
sujet et du coup j'avais proposé de
faire une deuxième vidéo sur l'avion
vert mais je lui proposer carrément
d'écrire le script donc c'est lui qui a
écrit au départ et ensuite ensuite on a
revu ensemble
et donc qu'est-ce qui est dit bah il est
dit en fait on explique un petit peu les
trois types de d'avions
comment dire à pas avion vert avion bas
carbone plutôt donc ça peut être
l'électricité
les biocarburants et l'hydrogène
et en gros il y a l'électricité c'est
pas du tout viable c'est beaucoup trop
lourd les batteries sont beaucoup trop
lourdes pour aller dans un avion donc ce
qu'on peut faire voler avec un avion
électrique c'est des batteries
ensuite il y a le biocarburant
vieux carburant ça pourrait marcher mais
en fait on a je crois que pour faire
voler tous les avions aujourd'hui il
faudrait 50% de l'agriculture de
d'aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est quoi le sol et pourtant
c'est que les avions c'est je crois
c'est 8 % du 8% de l'utilisation du
pétrole
donc ça ferait 50% de l'agriculture pour
les 8% de l'aviation donc c'est pas
vraiment viable non plus et après à
l'hydrogène et l'hydrogène c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué ça pourrait
marcher en gros pour les les avions
court courrier vous voir moyen courrier
mais on a toujours les
il faut pouvoir fabriquer l'hydrogène de
façon neutre en carbone ce qui est pour
l'instant c'est pas le cas
et quand on met tous les trois solutions
ensemble enfin il y en a plus ou moins
que deux mais si on met toutes les
solutions ensemble en fait
même dans des scénarios
ultra favorables à l'aviation par
exemple biocarburant 100% des
biocarburants vont pour l'aviation donc
des hypothèses vraiment même pas même
pas réalistes même en faisant ça le
l'avion l'aviation ne peut
[Musique]
progresser que de 0,8% par an
et aujourd'hui on est à 8% par an
et puis je ferai un moment dans cette
vidéo il y a une courbe de la
l'augmentation de la consommation de la
version enfin de personnes qui prennent
de l'avion de la journée plutôt et ça
augmente très très vite par rapport à
8 % par an avant clovie de 8 % et puis
je crois que c'est reparti à 8% après
depuis 2022
en fait moi je sur ma chaîne je veux
développer le climat c'est vraiment un
truc
même pour les en tant que conférencier
moi je m'engue je veux m'engager pour le
climat parce que c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse et qui est un petit peu
importe et du coup
j'ai commencé par une vidéo très
générale sur le climat l'implication de
l'homme etc
et ensuite je fais des plus petites
parties qui reprennent un petit peu tous
les thèmes qu'on peut aborder par
rapport à cette question et l'avion
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui tient à
cœur parce que c'est moi je suis un
grand voyageur et c'est ce qui me pose
le plus de problèmes alors ça m'en pose
pas trop en ce moment parce que depuis
le covid je voyage plus mais
enfin moi j'aime bien partir
assez loin au Népal par exemple ou en
Amérique du Sud j'aimerais bien aller et
du coup c'est un problème et je sais pas
ce que je vais faire mais en tout cas
j'avais besoin de savoir qu'est-ce que
ça ça faisait voilà
c'est presque un message à toi-même
cette vidéo
oui et puis après il y aura la viande il
y aura enfin il y aura toutes les choses
qui sont pas forcément le foot
et donc j'imagine que cette vidéo t'a
préparation aurait de faire cette vidéo
non pas vraiment en fait je pense juste
il faut il faut réfléchir à la façon
dont on voyage et peut-être pas prendre
l'avion tous les ans mais après
moi je vais pas m'interdire de prendre
l'avion
par contre il faut trouver un moyen de
le faire le mieux possible et pour
l'instant les solutions que j'ai c'est
de partir vraiment longtemps
ce que je faisais déjà avant donc
minimum un mois pour dire ok je passais
un mois quelque part loin j'en profite
et puis et puis pendant deux trois ans
je prends plus l'avion
les gens qui connaissent bien ma chaîne
savent que j'aime bien voyager aussi
j'avoue que si également depuis le covid
j'ai pas voyagé et je pense que j'ai mis
j'ai fait une croix plus ou moins en
voyage
longtemps ce qui leur quelques petits
problèmes parce que ma famille qui me
pousse à aller au Vietnam par exemple
c'est compliqué
mais après moi j'ai la chance de vivre
en Suisse où il y a beaucoup de
montagnes beaucoup de paysages je me
disais c'est de profiter ça ça me
prendra
toute une vidéo
bah écoute moi c'est pareil maintenant
que je suis j'ai toujours voulu vivre à
la montagne et maintenant que je suis à
Nice bah en fait c'est vrai qu'on a
moins besoin de voyager parce que tout
est là
parfois je plains un peu les Parisiens à
chaque fois que je vais apparaître
j'avais des super Jobs j'avais des super
Jobs proposés à Paris
la qualité de vie c'est important et ça
passe par le
coucou donc je propose passer à je sais
pas si tu as quelque chose d'autre à
ajouter sinon je passe te propose de
passer à la vidéo suivante
donc la vidéo suivante si je me souviens
bien c'est celle qui parle de foot
donc le titre c'est faut-il boycotter la
Coupe du Monde 2022 au 14 donc là
j'imagine c'était aussi un message à toi
même
alors oui et non oui non
en fait j'ai plus ça va plus je prends
mes distances facilement avec le foot
donc
ça me fait ça m'embête un petit peu mais
en fait
plus j'envoie et plus je me dis mais non
mais c'est pas possible d'aimer le foot
en fait
on peut plus aimer le foot quand j'ai vu
qu'il y a Mbappe se marrer et je me suis
dit mais j'avais déjà écrit le script
et j'avais prévu j'avais prévu et en
plus j'aimais bien ce joueur j'avais
prévu de le mettre de mettre un de ses
buts et puis enfin et puis finalement je
sais plus si je l'ai laissé mais
ça m'a
en fait ça me facilite les choses quand
même
des choses quand je vois et puis quand
je vois Zidane qui a qui qui a dit il
faut laisser les polémiques de côté
sachant que la plus grave la plus grave
c'est quand même les 6500 morts dans les
chantiers
c'est ça devient de plus en plus facile
de dire tant pis je boycotte en fait
tu veux parler un peu du contenu de la
vidéo
[Musique]
pour une raison simple c'est qu'il y a
pas de il y a pas de source
il y avait que les sources de la FIFA
donc c'est pas une source qu'on peut
dire fiable
et il y en a qu'une le seul truc c'est
qu'après on peut comparer entre les
différents rapports de la FIFA
éventuellement
donc je m'étais basée sur vraiment très
peu il y avait juste une autre source
qui contredisait un petit peu le bilan
mais pour faire un résumé en gros l'idée
c'était de montrer
[Musique]
que ce genre de que les événements
sportifs de cette envergure ont une
empreinte carbone importante
tous
que la clim la climatisation qui a fait
beaucoup débats finalement
[Musique]
symboliquement c'est je trouve ça grave
symboliquement
parce que
ah c'est pas c'est un peu le c'est pas
grave si il fait chaud avec la clim
c'est pas grave s'il y a pas de neige on
va en fabriquer peu importe on va
réussir à le faire avec l'argent on peut
tout faire donc symboliquement ça pose
gros problème par contre
en termes de chiffres la clim c'est
clairement pas un vrai problème en fait
donc ça j'avais envie de dire ça un
petit peu et faire de la neige
artificielle CO2 parlant c'était pas
vraiment un problème non plus
après il y a peut-être des histoires de
ressources d'eau qui sont un petit peu
plus compliquées mais en termes de CO2
c'était c'est pas forcément un si grand
problème le problème c'est les avions
qui arrivent et qui partent et là j'ai
vu que
ils avaient passé le logement donc ils
font des navettes en avion quoi entre
les pays entre je sais plus c'est quoi
le pays à côté entre Dubaï et
et c'est eux qui font la Coupe du monde
voilà je me suis un petit peu perdu dans
ce que je disais là
ouais bon bah voilà et puis
l'idée c'était plutôt d'aborder l'angle
climatique parce que moi tout ce qui
enfin les morts les morts dans les
accidents c'était c'était pas le sujet
même si on est obligé de le mentionner
et du coup que qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut
il faut pas regarder la Coupe du monde
voilà si on peut
frappant aussi dans cette vidéo c'est
lorsque tu as parlé de
des émissions CO2 suite au construction
et à quel point le rapport est de la
FIFA je crois ça et tu t'es trompeur
parce que finalement tu sais ça sur
sur 50 ans alors que ouais
je m'en suis rendu compte quand j'ai
comparé les différents rapports de la
FIFA en fait j'arrivais pas en fait
parce qu'ils sont pas construits de la
même façon il y a pas les mêmes trucs
et est-ce que ce que je vais reprocher
là tout de suite au rapport du Qatar on
peut le rapprocher aussi aux autres
d'avant
donc à la Russie notamment enfin au
moins Russie et je pense Russie Brésil
et l'Afrique du Sud c'est un petit peu
le même combat
donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que ils
ont compté les émissions de
carbone généré par la construction de
des 7 stades
6 ou 7 stade permanente et puis ils ont
divisé par le temps d'utilisation
pendant la coupe du monde c'est-à-dire
77 70 jours je crois donc
sachant que ça dure à peu près 60 ans et
stade c'est à dire qu'en gros il y a 59
ans et 300 jours qui sont pas comptés
dans l'empreinte carbone de la Coupe du
monde
donc ça c'est pas grave si les stats
sont effectivement utilisés pendant 60
ans correctement mais il y a des raisons
de douter que ce que ça arrive parce que
six ou cette stats dans une ville quoi
dans une ville le Qatar il faut c'est
pas vraiment
grosse culture foot non plus quoi
parce que si je joue quand ça joue en
été peut-être mettre la clim à ce
moment-là peut-être que ça va compter
tout le temps
partout je crois au Qatar il me semble
sinon dernière partie de la vidéo où tu
poses une question qui est plus de
l'ordre
politique ou philosophie morale je sais
pas trop comment dire ça mais faites
poser la question est-ce que ce genre
d'événements de Maxi événements
à sa place encore dans la société
ouais ouais en fait c'est ça c'est que
si on fait une coupe du monde en France
il y aura aussi une émission carbone
importante
d'ailleurs les JO de de Paris 2024
l'empreinte sera très importante donc la
question c'est est-ce que on continue à
faire ça et
là il y a pas de réponse j'ai ma réponse
que je que je propose ma réponse c'est
dans la mesure où c'est quand même un
événement hyper joyeux hyper
attendu
moi je serais plutôt pour dire on fait
au mieux
on fait au mieux au niveau CO2 pour pour
continuer à faire ce genre de choses qui
est important quand même je trouve
moi je pense qu'elle est la question est
vraiment
il y a quoi vraiment la poussée c'est je
pense qu'il y a vraiment les loin dans
cette question
en faisant les pour et les contres et
par exemple enfin si on est conscience
conséquentialiste on va réfléchir aux
conséquences d'avoir sur leurs
événements en tout cas je pense en effet
en termes environnemental c'est assez
problématique mais après on peut se
poser des questions est-ce que enfin moi
la question que je me suis posée c'est
est-ce que ce genre d'événements
augmente ou diminue les tensions
géopolitiques
en Chine avaient aussi une dimension
géopolitique assez importante dans une
trêve c'est demander de pas faire la
guerre pendant les JO et tout ça
il y a aussi des rencontres de
différentes personnes après il y a aussi
des démonstrations de pouvoir
dans le cas du Qatar il y a aussi cette
histoire de de d'application de
télécharger pour avoir les billets des
places pour les matchs qui est qui sera
un spyer en tout cas qui a des droits
assez bizarre
donc il y a beaucoup de questions qui se
posent en fait derrière cet événement
ouais mais c'est ça c'est une bonne
question mais il faut que tu fasses une
vidéo sur le sujet
là clairement j'ai pas la réponse à ça
je pense que c'est clair que c'est comme
c'est comme des vaccins le bénéfice
bénéfice risque de la d'un événement
sportif mondial comme ça ça se pose je
pense faut pas il faut pas regarder que
le CO2 c'est vrai regardez que le CO2 si
demain on dit ça va permettre de
développer le Qatar qui est un pays
hyper pauvre
tout le monde va venir jouer au foot il
va s'enrichir grâce à ça ça peut avoir
des je dis n'importe quoi mais ça s'il y
a des bénéfices comme ça ça peut vouloir
le coup de dépenser du CO2 finalement
il y a pas mal cette réflexion chez les
chez les militants de savoir est-ce que
ça met la lumière sur un problème au
Qatar
et puis après il y a aussi la question
est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a la lumière
dessus mais ce que en décembre après la
Coupe du Monde est-ce que la lumière
c'est encore dessus
c'est un peu ouais c'est ce que j'ai vu
ces
on en profite tant qu'on a le dessus et
puis après peut-être qu'on pourra plus
rien dire quoi
il y a un autre truc qui m'a un peu
frappé dans ce phénomène c'est que il y
a je crois que c'était même Zidane il y
a des joueurs de foot ou des
organisateurs de la Coupe du Monde qui
qui insistait qu'il faille se concentrer
sur le foot et pas avec le reste était
extra football et pas en parler
enfin c'est une attitude assez
récurrente
ouais dès qu'il y a un truc qui pose
problème donc forcément on va demander
de pas en parler si on est les
ordinateurs mais on peut même s'en
servir comme outil pour taire des
discussions voilà il y a l'événement de
foot il faut parler de foot alors que
bon il y a d'autres choses à côté et ça
peut permettre de réduire l'attention
qu'il y a à ces autres aspects
on peut pas séparer on peut pas séparer
le foot il y a le foot il y a la Coupe
du Monde c'est la Coupe du Monde c'est
pas que du sport quoi on peut pas
séparer c'est pas possible donc quand on
dit faut se concentrer sur le foot moi
ça m'inspire
de dire ça c'est des choses qui sont
trop trop graves trop grave
je suis très d'accord avec ce pendu
après après les commentateurs quand ils
vont commenter les matchs bah là leur
job c'est de parler de foot là pas de
souci mais
c'est spécifique
il se trouve que j'avais vu en direct
je paye un match à Roland-Garros un
moment et avait une mi-temps qui s'était
attachée au filet je me suis à
l'événement que je fais référence
et je me souviens avoir je trouve que je
regardais en direct je regarde pas
beaucoup le tennis mais bon voilà je
regardais direct et les commentateurs
étaient très mauvais enfin ils avaient
pas deviné le lien avec le changement
climatique
un message de vue symbolique et tout ça
et les commentateurs pensaient qu'elle
parlait de l'Apocalypse
dans 3 ans en tout cas
je me rappelais plus de ça je me
rappelle qu'ils étaient horribles et
commentateurs
alors moi je suis plus partagé sur le
sur le l'acte en soi pareil avec les
pots de peinture là sur les tableaux
enfin les bol de soupe je suis partagé
en fait j'ai pas d'avis parce que je
sais pas
je sais pas si c'est contre-productif ou
pas on en parle mais est-ce qu'on en
parle en bien je sais pas mais en tout
cas j'avais été choqué par la réaction
des gens en fait c'est
le tennis c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
important on peut pas
et les commentateurs je me rappelle je
me rappelais je croyais qu'ils avaient
compris pour le changement climatique
mais je croyais que juste il trouvait ça
anormal que des gens viennent me
viennent faire un acte alors qu'il y
avait un match de tennis de fou quoi il
était génial ce match de tennis c'était
le meilleur de tous les temps en plus tu
vois donc voilà
j'avais dit un truc à dire mais bon
d'autres choses à rajouter sur cette
vidéo ou
c'est non juste c'est pas c'est pas ma
préférée parce qu'elle est moins
scientifique mais du coup elle est plus
engagée voilà oui
normalement je fais la distinction à ce
niveau-là
je me souviens de ce que je voulais dire
j'ai un problème avec mon micro
ça casser des choses
[Musique]
tu m'entends bien tu m'entends tout
court
non
est-ce que tu m'entends
ça a coupé
tu m'entends
est-ce que le chat menton
ok ok
donc on est revenu alors ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que
je pense qu'il y a des différences aussi
dans les actions donc par exemple le
coût de la soupe sur les sur les œuvres
en fait il y a eu littéralement enfin
essentiellement qui endommage même à
l'oeuvre en tant que tel donc bon le
symbole est fort mais il y a pas
il y a pas mort d'homme il y a pas eu de
nuisances à personne physique
là où c'est un peu différent pas lorsque
il y a des manifestations qui bloquent
par exemple des routes surtout aux
heures de pointe à Paris là par contre
ça dérange enfin c'est il y a
potentiellement un coup
pour les personnes que ça que ça bloque
et donc je mettrai pas dans le même
panier en tout cas ces deux
interventions comme
sans dire que
peut-être en justifier ou justifiable je
mais en tout cas il y a le balance que
vous bénéfice est plus compliqué dans le
second cas alors que dans le premier cas
ça me semble assez nettement
ne pas causer trop de tort
en fait il faudrait voir
parce qu'en pensent les gens en fait
parce que
moi pour moi je trouve ça bien je dis ok
on en parle c'est bien après pour des
gens qui sont
plus
moins dans la bulle climat qui s'enfile
qui s'en foutent un peu
qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent et si la
plupart il pense que c'est n'importe
quoi alors alors c'est contre-productif
parce que ça fait des
ça fait des milliers ça fait comme si
les écolos ils étaient chiant quoi
donc
et malheureusement les écolos déjà est
déjà
il faut le dire les écolos c'est chiant
moi je suis chiant mais
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui doivent faire des
choses et en fait c'est quoi les autres
façons de faire il y a peut-être des
façons plus intelligentes de
militer pour une cause je pense
je sais pas si c'est très utile de faire
ça comme ça
parce que il passe à la télé mais il
passe à la télé et puis il est
c'est pas forcément une bonne image qui
est donnée en fait
ok c'était d'autres choses à rajouter à
cette vidéo
on va pouvoir passer à la première
comparaison de vidéos
donc pour ceux qui connaissent pas du
coup j'ai lancé co-fondé avec
un groupe de gens extrêmement brillant
la plateforme tourne au sol ou l'idée
c'est d'essayer d'identifier les vidéos
d'utilité publique
comme par exemple les vidéos de Michael
en tout cas ces deux vidéos ont été jugé
par les contributeurs de tournesol comme
étant de trêve à recommander vivement
alors n'importe qui peut créer son
propre compte sur tournesol donc je
redonne le lien dans le chat et vous
pouvez ainsi influencer les
recommandations de tournesol et
peut-être mais le https ça passe
vraiment
je sais pas si ça fait un lion en fait
voilà et puis je vais même donner le
lien de la comparaison que l'on va faire
dans le chat donc si vous avez un compte
tournesol vous pouvez cliquer sur le
lien et si vous amènera directement à
cette page de comparaison donc
d'habitude vous pouvez faire ça donc la
plupart du temps ceux qui vont comparer
les vidéos ne sont pas les créateurs de
de ces vidéos mais là on a la chance
d'avoir Michael du coup on va pouvoir
demander à Mickaël d'après toi laquelle
de cette vidéo devrait être la plus
largement recommandée
ça c'est difficile à dire
[Musique]
en fait ah ouais en fait on peut
comparer des vidéos qui sont pas sur le
même sujet parce que j'avais pas compris
enfin j'ai compris la récemment mais au
départ j'avais pas compris
donc l'idée à la place de la gorille de
YouTube et voilà tu as plein de gens qui
faut recommander des vidéos et puis bon
il y a qu'une seule recommandation ou
que quelques recommandations à faire
pour chacun donc il faut quand même
choisir
et là dans ce cas bah où est-ce que tu
mets le curseur plutôt un peu plus des
vidéos de recommandations de vidéos de
gauche ou de la vidéo de droite
alors
franchement elle est horrible cette
comparaison moi moi je suis moi je suis
j'aime beaucoup plus ma vidéo sur
l'avion personnellement parce que les
plus riches scientifiquement
l'autre elle est un peu comme je disais
tout à l'heure il y a moins de source
et en terme d'impact
moi je dirais recommander le Qatar tout
de suite et puis après
recommander l'autre plus tard
après la Coupe du Monde
Qatar a moins besoin de recommander
forcément
quoi que le message reste important et
valide d'une certaine manière
pour aujourd'hui ou pour le mois de
allez je le mets juste un petit peu à
droite tu peux à droite
de croire
alors sur tournesol vous pouvez faire
répondre juste à cette question qui est
la question un peu obligatoire enfin
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avancer mais
vous pouvez aussi être plus
plus bavard ou plus
enfin nous dire plus sur le pourquoi de
ses préférences et du coup il y a plus
il y a d'autres
critères de comparaison
et donc là je vais demander à Mickaël de
nous dire à chaque fois laquelle enfin
plutôt gauche ou plutôt droite
donc par exemple pour le critère fiable
et non trompeur
alors là ça va à gauche bien à gauche
comme ça ça va
plus je vois pas
à gauche
ouais ok c'est bon
car pédagogique
de seconde
du coup je vais décrire à voix haute
que je peux partager mon
non mais c'est pas grave on peut faire
comme ça je te dis combien de Crans à
gauche ou à droite alors claire et
pédagogique gauche ou droite
à gauche
je suis assez d'accord avec tout ce qui
est même si en tant que créateur
peut-être que ton avis devrait avoir un
avis supérieur mais
important et actionnable
je dirais quatre cinq ans à la droite
accessible non spécialiste
[Musique]
je dirais 5 ans à droite
divertissant et relaxant
alors là tu peux mettre tu peux laisser
au milieu c'est l'horreur c'est
l'horreur mes vidéos
ok j'ai assez vieux
il y a plus de blagues pour détendre un
peu l'atmosphère je les ai pas évident
en fait il y a une qui a des images de
foot
un petit peu
à droite alors à droite
ensuite c'est stimulant et suscite la
réflexion
de croix à droite de creux à droite
diversité et inclusion
tu peux me m'expliquer un peu mieux
cette catégorie typiquement ça serait
est-ce que ça fait réfléchir à des
personnes auxquelles on pense pas assez
parce que ça
intègre est-ce que le message pour aussi
bien passer à plus de
gens plus divers et variés
[Musique]
ouais je pense là tu peux mettre tu peux
tout mettre 6 ou 7 crans à droite
encourage de meilleures habitudes
au milieu
il y a quelqu'un qui écrit dans le
train de demander à son invité lequel de
tes enfants tu aimes le plus
c'est exactement ça
moi je dis souvent à ma fille que c'est
ma fille préférée et à mon fils que
c'est mon fils préféré c'est
résistant en retour négatif typiquement
quelqu'un qui un peu réfractaire à ses
idées à quel point est-ce que ça le
rebute encore plus
où est-ce que ça empêche ça
donc ça va ça empêche ça
alors là c'est beaucoup à gauche je
pense
plus de supporters de foot que de gens
qui prennent l'avion
ok c'est enregistré alors il faudrait
que c'est enregistré avec un compte que
j'écris pour l'occasion qui s'appelle
tournesol live
donc
notamment enfin ces données seront
publiques et on saura que ça vient de
toi et du coup on espère aussi que ça va
motiver la recherche dans le domaine et
que typiquement savoir ce que la vie des
créateurs est aligné avec la vie de la
plupart des contributeurs de tournesol
je pense que c'est une question
intéressante
une question que vous voulez reprendre
que je voulais remonter un petit peu
dans
le chat
ah oui il y a quelqu'un qui demandait
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire pareil pour
les articles scientifiques alors c'est
un projet
justement en train de parler de détendre
d'abord au livre donc comparer des
livres et après on espère faire des
articles scientifiques sachant que le
problème c'est surtout d'avoir des
contributeurs au niveau développement ça
va
donc j'espère que je vous encourage à
tous ceux dans le chat à faire aussi ce
travail et à vous intéresser à cette
plateforme
ok on va passer à la prochaine vidéo
de Michael
qui est
est alors la prochaine vidéo
c'est une vidéo qui s'appelle
je sais même problème
je vois l'image mais s'écrit trop petit
sur mon écran pour voir les titres donc
le titre c'est limité la vitesse à 110
km/h sur autoroute une vraie bonne idée
pour le climat point d'interrogation
tu peux nous parler de cette vidéo
alors ça c'est une vidéo que j'ai fait
quelques mois je crois
donc c'est je crois que c'est quand
Elisabeth borne elle a été élue on a
reparlé de
limiter la vitesse à 110 km/h sur
autoroute au lieu de 130 ce qui avait
déjà été proposé mais pas accepté par la
Convention citoyenne
il y a quelques temps et donc ça c'est
un script que a été relu par Aurélien
Bigot qui a fait sa thèse sur un sujet
qui englobait
qui englobé cette question là et donc en
fait oui plus moins en roule vite
et moi on pollue et moi on aimait de CO2
et moi on pollue tout court donc il y a
une différence de
16% en moyenne ça peut être plus oui
c'est une moyenne
[Musique]
sur les sur les grosses voitures c'est
souvent plus la différence
et c'est en fait c'est immédiat c'est tu
fais ça bah tu as 16 % de tous les
trajets sur autoroute en moins pour les
émissions de CO2
il y a un élément qui m'avait pas mal
frappé dans cette vidéo c'est l'idée
selon laquelle face à la question de un
peu l'effet remonte enfin c'est on va
plus vite parce que je passais un rebond
mais plus on va vite plus on voyage loin
et en particulier le
ce qui compte c'est plus le temps de
trajet quoi
alors ça c'est sur les effets un peu
indirects c'est que
en fait depuis je sais plus le graphe
d'où il part mais il part de
je crois qu'il part de au moins 200 ans
en arrière
et en fait le temps de trajet je sais
pas comment ils ont fait pour savoir le
temps de trajet il y a 200 ans mais
il y a un graphe en tout cas et
en fait le temps de trajet ça doit c'est
peut-être pas 200 ans faudrait vérifier
le en tout cas le temps de trajet depuis
longtemps c'est toujours le même c'est
toujours la même exactement il y a une
variation de même pas de peut-être un ou
deux pour cent grand max
et pourtant on va beaucoup plus vite
donc faites plus on va vite et plus
on peut aller loin finalement
et du coup le fait de réduire la vitesse
indirectement
[Musique]
ça fait qu'on va moins
aussi parce que si vous devez aller
voir la famille qui habite à
8h de route par exemple 8 heures de
route bah tiens vous allez le faire tous
les trois mois par exemple et si en fait
il y a finalement il y a 10 heures de
route
vous allez le faire peut-être tous les
quatre mois voilà ça c'est un peu l'idée
moi on va vite moi on va loin
et c'est un peu aussi l'idée de
du 30 km heure en ville
ouais non c'est pas tout à fait pareil
je retire
tu peux parler du 30 km heure en ville
du coup
ouais 30 km/h en vide en fait
on peut lui à peu près pareil à 30 et à
50 parce que
[Musique]
en gros en gros les études elles
montrent que c'est des fois c'est un peu
plus des fois c'est un peu moins et
parce que en gros on pollue plus à 30
km/h qu'à 50 km/h si on roule tout le
temps en moyenne à cette vitesse là par
contre si on roule à 30 km/h on accélère
moins entre 0 et 30 et du coup l'un dans
l'autre c'est pas clair la la différence
et l'idée je pense en gros l'idée de je
sais pas je suis pas très favorable à ça
c'est l'idée du 30 km heure c'est de
dire aux gens arrêtez de prendre la
voiture
et ça ça marche s'il y a des solutions
alternatives ce qui est pas forcément le
cas moi s'il y a des solutions
alternatives je dis mais oui carrément
mais il y a des fois quand on a deux
enfants qu'on doit les amener à 5 km
de chez nous bah on peut on est obligé
de prendre la voiture plus ou moins
donc en effet une difficulté
donc l'autre question c'est comment
est-ce que tu en es arrivé à faire cette
vidéo
les questions d'actualité des fois je
vois un sujet je trouve ça intéressant
typiquement moi c'est si on m'avait dit
ça il y a par exemple 5 ans
je pense que j'aurais dit un truc du
genre exactement les mêmes arguments que
là on me sort
sur ma vidéo c'est à dire non j'ai pas
envie j'ai envie de rouler vite
il y a pas une grosse différence
finalement de
d'émission entre les deux vitesses
j'aurais pas été content je pense mais
j'ai pas mal changé là-dessus
dans le cas il y a pas mal de blagues
sur les Mille Bornes et le nom de la
ministre
il y a quelqu'un qui demande est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas limiter les lieux de
la vitesse des avions est-ce que ça
un impact
est-ce que tu sais je pense que ça moi
je pense que ça pourrait être pas mal
dans certains cas éventuellement parce
que la consommation elle varie plus ou
moins avec le carré de la vitesse en
plus donc
moi c'est ce que je me suis dit quand
j'ai fait la vidéo mais j'ai trouvé ça
parce que je pense que si on divise par
deux la vitesse ça va encore vite quoi
par exemple on pourrait avoir des des
vols lents exprès peut-être je sais pas
c'est à étudier peut-être
parce que d'un point de vue physique en
fait c'est le frottement de l'air qui
augmente contraintiquement avec la
vitesse
donc je pensais que aller vite c'est
aussi se battre avec plus de frottement
de l'air et donc il faut plus d'énergie
coucou donc ce que tu as d'autres choses
à rajouter
non c'est à peu près tout je pense du
coup on va passer à la comparaison
comparer tes enfants
là on va les comparer
alors on peut laisser les curseurs au
milieu
c'est un signal un peu intéressant aussi
pour la gorille c'est une question qu'on
a souvent sur tourne au sol lorsqu'on
laisse curseur mieux ça veut dire qu'on
pense que les deux vidéos doivent être
recommandées aussi souvent que et en
fait c'est une information intéressante
parce que si tu commences une vidéo qui
a été beaucoup noté et que l'autre elle
a jamais été notée dire que les deux
doivent être notés autant aussi souvent
bah ça permet de dire que celles qui a
rarement noté elle doit avoir une bonne
note quand même
et donc entre ces deux vidéos
gauche ou droite
tout à l'heure j'avais mis le Qatar je
pense que pour les mêmes raisons on va
remettre en fait elles sont un peu très
comparables la vidéo sur l'avion et la
vitesse des voitures je pense
donc tu mettras
moi j'ai l'impression que la vidéo de
droite est quand même plus importante
que
celle sur les avions dans le sens où
c'est comme une mesure assez concrète
sur lequel il y a des débats en cours
et
puis je trouvais que le message
ouais alors on met on peut mettre au
milieu ça m'arrange que tu me m'obliges
pas à choisir entre mes enfants ça
m'arrange
c'est c'est ton avis c'est enregistré
autant que ton avis
c'est pas mon compte
dans les détails de comparaison
alors fiable et non trompeur gauche ou
droite
pédagogique
[Musique]
sur le la vitesse elle est ultra claires
parce que j'aime bien dans la vidéo de
gauche c'est que tu parles de
on sent que ça que ça fait un peu chier
quoi cette histoire
et je trouve que ça accompagne bien à
quelqu'un qui serait un peu réticent à
ces idées quoi il y a un côté
alors moi pour info j'ai du coup je fais
ça je roule à 110 sur autoroute
maintenant ok du coup je suis passé je
suis passé à une consommation de
je sais pas une étude scientifique mais
en gros je suis passé de 7, entre 7 et
7,5 je pense plutôt 7,5
6,2 jours
c'est mieux comme ça
important et actionnable
tu peux laisser au milieu
accessible non spécialiste
[Musique]
elle est simple non celle-là
divertissant et relaxant
je crois qu'il y avait quelques blagues
sur celle de droite aussi
au milieu
tu m'as dit il y a du il y a quand même
du foot à gauche quand même
stimulant et
à gauche
diversité et inclusion
là c'est au milieu ça concerne tout le
monde pour les quasiment tout le monde
ouais peut-être quand même encore un ou
deux cran à gauche parce que
encourage de meilleurs habitudes
meilleurs habitudes tu peux mettre à
droite du coup
au moins très à droite OK
résistant au retour négatif
attends tu me rappelles c'est quelqu'un
qui est un peu réfractaire aux idées
est-ce que
tu arrives à l'amener avec toi ou est-ce
que
je pense je pense 3 à droite
ce que tu veux réviser ton jugement
initial
sur quel devrait être plus recommandée à
la lumière de
cette analyse
non c'est bon
on va parler d'une autre vidéo qui est
pas encore bien recommandé sur tournesol
il y a une raison à ça c'est que les pas
encore très noté
donc quand les vidéos sont pas très
notées
elles ont un score en fait c'est des
questions de pour des raisons de
sécurité en fait elles ont des scores
qui sont encore proches de zéro
avec
le gros problème c'est les flocons qu'on
risque d'être créé sur la plateforme et
donc on ce qu'on veut absolument pas
c'est que faucontre prennent la pire
vidéo qui a sur sur Youtube et lui donne
des excellentes et s'il pouvait
manipuler ce score comme il voulait bah
du coup les tops recommandations de
tournesol serait en fait complètement
manipulé par ces seuls individus et en
fait quand même c'est une de mes
frayeurs c'est le jour la top
recommandation de tournesol et un truc
nazi je sais pas trop quoi
je vais très mal dormir ce jour-là
donc pour éviter ça en gros l'influence
de chaque contributeur est finie et
illimité et du coup il faut vraiment
qu'il y ait pas mal de gens qui notent
une vidéo pour qu'elle commence à voir
une note qui est soit représentative des
avis des contributeurs
donc la vidéo je suis en train de je te
coupe parce que je suis en train de voir
des des questions sur la vidéo d'avant
là je sais pas exactement c'est quoi la
question mais il y a plusieurs personnes
qui m'ont mis en commentaire c'est pas
vrai moi quand je roule à 130 à 150 avec
ma voiture je consomme moins que lui
avec qui roule à
110 ça c'est possible mais quand on dit
qu'il y a une différence de 16%, c'est
pour la même voiture qui roule soit 130
70 je sais pas si c'était ça la question
j'ai juste vu passer des trucs mais je
comme j'ai eu pas mal de commentaires
là-dessus je peux dire ça
[Musique]
vas-tu lancer une seconde vague de ville
et de gilets jaunes avec ta vidéo sur la
vitesse sur autoroute
qu'il y aura pas de d'efforts demain à
cause de cette vidéo
ça va je pense qu'avec il y a 2000 3000
vues
sur la
l'acceptabilité de mesure contraignantes
environnementales s'il y a pas
suffisamment de compréhension et de
vulgarisation de ces enjeux au grand
public la probabilité que ça soit mal
reçu par la population
est plus grande donc je pense que c'est
ces vidéos enfin voilà on parle un peu
comme ça comme si Stephen mais je pense
que c'est vraiment très important en
fait de
produire des vidéos de qualité et mais
également qu'elle fasse beaucoup de vues
et de bien le recommander
discours classique mais le nombre de
vues d'une vidéo Youtube aujourd'hui
c'est en gros son nombre de
recommandations le clic to wait pas
énormément
mais par contre ils peuvent varier d'un
facteur 10 donc il va quand même mais il
varie pas d'un facteur 10 max et
légèrement c'est plus un facteur 2 ou 3
par contre le nombre de recommandations
lui varie facilement d'un facteur mine
ou un million si on compare
out à d'autres par exemple
donc c'est la God donc on a vraiment
très très important et
je pense en particulier pour des causes
comme la cause environnementale
c'est vraiment vraiment très très
important de faire attention à ce que
cet algorithme recommande
il y a Mister Coop qui demande
n'avez-vous pas peur d'influencer les
contributeurs en fournissant en libre
assez la comparaison des influenceurs
cela ne risque-t-il pas de biaiser les
données de la plateforme
ce que tu risques de trop influencer les
contributeurs tournesol
ou après je pense pas
il y aura toujours un petit effet
après
bon j'espère d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de
mettre le lien dans le chat
oublie les liens sont dans les
descriptifs sur Youtube en tout cas de
la vidéo vous pouvez cliquer dessus si
vous faire les comparaisons en même
temps que nous
ok donc on passe à vidéo suivante donc
ça s'appelle réchauffement climatique
cause conséquences et solutions donc je
t'avais demandé de sélectionner une
vidéo qui était la meilleure selon toi
parmi tes vidéos
est-ce que tu as changé d'avis ou c'est
encore la dernière vidéo que tu as
produite selon toi
non j'avais pas compris que c'était la
meilleure vidéo je croyais que c'était
celle que qui devait être le plus
recommandé
ouais bah du coup celle-là oui
j'aimerais bien qu'elle soit plus
recommandée effectivement tu peux nous
la décrire
ouais ben ça c'est un c'est une revue
très globale du réchauffement climatique
de comment on sait que l'homme est
responsable de tout ce qui est toutes
les causes enfin pas toutes les causes
enfin il y a qu'une cause mais les
causes les conséquences c'est vraiment
un
c'est la première vidéo de climat que
j'ai fait sur ma chaîne c'est fait pour
vraiment englober tout ce que ensuite je
vais revenir dessus mais de façon plus
précise
voilà
est-ce que ça parle de biologie sur ta
chaîne
mais c'est pas c'est pas une chaîne de
biologie c'est la biologie qui fait des
vidéos c'est ça
qui est de moins en moins fort
non mais moi en fait il y a aussi un
truc que j'aime beaucoup avec
ma chaîne c'est vraiment de parler de
choses que je ne connais pas
[Musique]
typiquement les vidéos que j'ai fait sur
le cancer c'est pas celle que j'ai le
plus aimé faire parce que j'ai pas j'ai
rien appris ou quasiment rien donc dans
la à chaque fois que je fais des vidéos
j'apprends beaucoup de choses et
ça nécessite par contre d'être relu plus
plus que si c'était vraiment mon domaine
et je me suis enfin je me sens beaucoup
plus légitime à quand c'est relu quoi
par exemple la vidéo sur le sur le
nucléaire il y a deux parties ces deux
c'est une heure en tout et là je
l'aurais jamais fait sans être lu et
c'est le réveil ailleurs qui m'a relu
ce qu'il y a des choses que tu as envie
de mettre en avant donc dans cette vidéo
dans le contenu dans cette vidéo c'est
une vidéo assez longue à 27 22 minutes
qui
est vidéo essaie de faire vraiment le
point sur
le réchauffement climatique par pas mal
de le fait de serre des différents
effets du CO2 du fait de la vapeur d'eau
les boucles de rétroaction
et donc en fait ça je comprends pourquoi
c'est parce que ça reprend vraiment le
la globalité du climat sans trop de
solution d'ailleurs j'aborde pas trop
les solutions je les listes je les
listes sur cette vidéo rapidement
est-ce que tu as d'autres choses à dire
sur cette vidéo avant le moment
fatidique
et difficile de la comparaison
moi j'aime bien cette vidéo c'est une de
mes préférées voilà donc je suis pas
très tu as pas peur de la comparaison
j'ai pas peur de la comparaison
et du coup entre le l'autoroute et cette
vidéo qui fait du coup
un résumé assez global des changements
climatique et des enjeux
là comme c'est plus global moi je la
recommanderais plus je mettrais
4 4 bons crans à droite
en rentrant dans les détails
donc qu'elle est plus fiable et non on
peut
là tu peux mettre comme c'est un peu
plus global c'est un petit peu moins
précis je dirais un cran à gauche
ok parce que je leur ai dit
le fait d'avoir une vision globale
c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup de choses
et des choses
[Musique]
pédagogique
je pense que celle de droite elle est
l'éclair est pédagogique mais elle est
peut-être un petit peu plus compliquée
donc je dirais
un ou deux crans à gauche aussi
j'ai mis un compte
important et actionnable
les deux sont importants actionnables il
y en a un c'est un petit truc qu'on peut
faire facilement l'autre
il y a plein de trucs qu'on peut faire
mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
tout faire voir impossible
[Musique]
ouais c'est plus actionnable à gauche
peut-être un cran à gauche alors
spécialiste il faut que j'arrive à la
faire mieux noter que l'autre quand même
à gauche
excessivement
pour moi
un cran à gauche aussi
c'est parti pour être un coin gauche
je reviens sur je peux revenir sur un
critère clair et pédagogique je pense
que en fait quand tu peux mettre au
milieu que la pédagogique
divertissant et relaxant
alors là tu peux mettre
trois à droite
je sais que ma femme elle m'avait dit
que c'était
tout ça mais
[Musique]
elle a été assez touché par la fin de la
vidéo ce qui est pas d'habitude ça
arrive pas mais
c'était une petite musique et puis on
entend Trump Greta de l'autre et puis je
liste un petit peu les conséquences
catastrophiques
donc divertissant et pas forcément
relaxant
c'est plus en fait c'est ça ouais c'est
pour ça ouais c'est ouais mais c'est
quand même marrant au début il est
marrant
stimulant et suscite la réflexion
ouais 3 3 4 coins à droite aussi
à tout à l'heure
diversité et inclusion
[Musique]
je pense qu'on peut les semer au milieu
tu parles quand même de tous les
réfugiés climatiques si je me souviens
bien
je me sens aussi à la fin on parle de
guerre parle pas de risque de guerre
ouais
du coup ça rentre dans diversité
inclusion ça ouais
c'est par contre les réfugiés
climatiques
ce que je pense que cette vidéo de
gauche reste enfin je pense que les gens
regardent la vidéo de gauche il pense
aux Français
ouais ok donc tu peux mettre un peu à
droite alors
à droite de la droite
encourage de meilleures habitudes
au milieu là il y en a il y en a
c'est un peu plus clair les habitudes
à prendre c'est parce que c'est plus
simple c'est plus simple
après l'autre il te dit arrête de manger
de la viande arrête de prendre la
voiture arrête de vivre
S qui sont pas d'accord donc plutôt à
droite plutôt à droite parce que
pas mal axé sur Trump
donc j'ai envie de dire que tous les
fans de Trump déjà sont risquent de mal
prendre la vidéo de droite
et tant de choses que ça sur Trump
a priori
tant que ça de supporters de Trump
aux États-Unis c'est comme la moitié je
pense que
tu prends dans le contexte mondial
les sondages moi j'y crois pas trop au
sondage sur la vitesse là genre 75% est
d'accord pour mettre à 110 ça m'étonne
vachement comme sondage
j'ai l'impression que la plupart des
gens ils veulent pas ils disent bah non
pourquoi pourquoi moi je vais baisser de
20 km/h ma vitesse alors que Bernard
Arnault Il a pollué autant que 1000
français dans l'année
alors que à droite les climats
il y en a peut-être plus tant que ça
en France ça a pas mal changé j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
d'acceptabilité des
frais je reprends le commentateur de
tennis
je sais pas ça
non mais c'est vrai que quand tu
regardes la télé en fait
ça fait peur quoi
entre nous clairement un changement
climatique
ouais c'est vrai qu'on est
je ressens très bien d'être complètement
dans une bulle
climat covid
du coup je laisse deux à droite ou
ouais ça me paraît bien quand même
OK et alors juste pour finir je l'avais
demandé alors je vais pas demander de
comparer ça sera un peu
visiblement politiquement correct on va
dire mais quand même parler de la vidéo
parce que j'aimerais toujours finir
c'est c'est live avec une vidéo choisie
par l'invité qui a beaucoup marqué qui
est
et donc voilà comme Michael a choisi
cette vidéo de science étonnante
le boss de la vulgaire
[Musique]
tu peux nous parler de pourquoi tu as
choisi cette vidéo qu'est-ce qui t'a
marqué
ouais alors quand tu m'as demandé vidéo
choisir autant te dire que j'en savais
rien parce que ça aurait pu être
200 vidéos différentes
mais
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour sur ces
tenants d'une façon générale parce que
je comprends pas que très bien comment
il fait mais
comment comment je peux aimer une vidéo
qui parle de la dualité entre particules
je ne sais pas
alors moi de basiquement je suis plus
déjà attiré vers les vidéos qui ne sont
pas de la biologie
ok
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup les vidéos sur Optima et
les vidéos de physique et
celle là celle là m'a passionné cette
vidéo là
tu connais le sujet avant
au moment où j'ai vu je pense que je
connaissais pas vraiment non je crois
pas
je pense pas je pense que je connaissais
quasi pas le sujet j'ai aucune base de
physique donc
j'ai trouvé en fait ce qu'il arrive à
faire sur étonnante dans ses vidéos
c'est prendre un sujet il fait pas de
montage
il fait pas de il fait presque pas de
blague ou alors que des blagues de
scientifique
qui m'amuse mais c'est pas si c'est le
cas pour tout le monde et pourtant il
arrive à passionner pendant 20 minutes
sur un sujet
incompréhensible en général et en fait
on comprend quand même on croit
comprendre en tout cas
et voilà ça c'est un peu la vidéo qui
à laquelle je pense quand je pense à lui
voilà
en fait il intègre quelque chose que
beaucoup de vulgarisateurs n'intègrent
pas qui est pourtant central à mon avis
qui est la méthode la méthode
la méthode c'est vraiment il y a des
très bonnes choses des chaînes de
sciences qui ont très très développée où
il parle pas de méthode et pourtant
c'est central
et moi j'essaye de le faire
mais quand on parle de quelque chose
d'un peu global c'est difficile c'est
difficile donc par exemple si on prend
la vidéo juste avant sur les méthodes
on parle un petit peu des carottes de
glace par exemple
donc je crois que c'est à peu près le
seul truc et c'est ça qui à mon avis lui
fait très très bien c'est que il fait la
il explique la méthode et l'histoire des
découvertes
ça fait tout ça très très bien
et puis
incroyable c'est juste un bus purement
statistique c'est que ces vidéos qui
comme j'ai dit ils sont pas forcément
toujours très travaillés alors parfois
il fait quand même des animations
directement lui-même parfois ça va être
même des articles de recherche
mais sinon ces vidéos sont assez
secs au centre il y a pas beaucoup de
fioritures
pourtant il fait 500 000 vues sur cette
vidéo par exemple
très impressionnant après les faut aussi
voir que les youtubeurs qu'on commençait
en 2014 ils ont la chance aussi d'avoir
eu je crois tu me diras si je me trompe
quand même la chance d'avoir un marché
plus facile d'accéder
beaucoup beaucoup d'abonnés et puis
après ça roule un peu plus aussi quoi
donc il y a un peu de ça aussi mais
voilà ça fait pas tous 500000 vues je
fais aussi la même époque de concernant
après après David
et puis il y a des sujets je suis
vraiment
je suis en grande admiration devant ce
pas pour un que j'appelle le boss de la
vulgaire
coucou bah voilà je pense qu'on a fait
le tour je sais pas si tu as deux choses
à rajouter c'est ce que tu voudrais dire
ben non écoute merci de m'avoir invité
je suis content d'avoir été le premier
c'est qui le prochain
c'est quelque chose j'ai pas encore
envoyé mais il y a beaucoup que j'ai
envie d'inviter
tous ceux qui ont des bonnes vidéos sur
tournesol et il y a quand même pas mal
de beau monde
donc je sais pas qui mais
ça va être cool et en tout cas merci
d'avoir été le premier et je suis assez
rassurant aussi que ça soit bien passé
j'avais un petit peu peur
et sur ce je vous remercie aussi à tous
les gens dans le chat d'être passé de
voir poser vos questions alors faut que
je prenne un peu plus l'habitude de lire
vos questions et tout ça ça va venir
mais bon là j'ai encore toujours tous
les bons réflexes
en tout cas merci à tous et
je vous dis à une prochaine
au